hello hey did you art all over your play
button that's awesome good morning John
while I was in Los Angeles I found
myself near Sarah sandall's house Sarah
is an artist back in 2016 she made over
100 individual unique t-shirts for the
perfect strangers tour and they were
awesome and we sold all of them and if
you still have one please post a picture
somewhere I would love to see them I
love Sarah's work and it was kind of a
fan moment to see this like amazing
little jamed packed garage Studio space
where a lot of the work comes from and
then I also got a tour the inside of her
house to find so much of her art on the
walls she told me she doesn't really
want it there it's just been harder to
sell since social media algorithms
changed and stopped featuring her work
as much we only had like an hour to hang
out so we hatched a little plan she
busted open two canvases and then
started building some layers for a
background on the first one Sarah's
immigration status can make some kinds
of work complicated for her but with a
mix of mural work and commissions and
tattoos it's a lot of different things
she's making it work in Los Angeles the
stuff that she was making on YouTube
when I first discovered her it was
pretty celebrity driven in part because
that's what was getting clicks during
the pandemic though she started to take
her work in more political directions
and I've absolutely loved seeing her
work change perspective and medium and
intent my favorites are her cute little
inklings and also her more Aztec
inspired work then I took on my canvas
I've been doing like a fair amount of
spray painting for project for awesome
stuff over the last few years I just
like smack down 20 canvases and then I
build layers to see what happens I find
spray paint such like a good medium for
me because like with a lot of what I do
it's very easy to iterate super fast so
many accidents happen but when you're
already on to the next thing an accident
feels more like inspiration than like
failure and with that ethos behind me I
was very happy to see that the thing I
was making in Sarah Studio actually
start to look kind of good like at least
not embarrassing and then there was the
core of the idea the swap I took her
canvas and she took mine and and we
arted on each other's art Sarah made one
of her skulls on mine which ended up
looking totally dope and I only know how
to do one thing so Sarah's canvas got a
Handler fish and look at this less than
an hour and we had made a thing together
this was like bizarrely dreamy for me
because I did so much on my trip to Los
Angeles but most of it there was a lot
of like layers to make it happen whereas
this was very pure and simple I don't
ever think of myself as an artist like I
don't maybe I should but I do love it
when two artists make a thing together
and I guess I feel like I got to be one
of those artists for a moment I loved
seeing Sarah work in real time her stuff
is such an interesting mix of the slow
focused laborious work of cutting paper
and then the fast but still finicky work
of spray paints her cut paper pieces are
especially striking closeup after I left
I texted Sarah and I told her that I
thought she should get her store back
online cuz I felt like people would like
her stuff if they knew that it existed
and so she got it up in record time it
is on the internet now you can check out
her work at Sarah sandoval.com I bet
there's a link in the description I
think her art Falls nicely into that
place where it's definitely like good
art from a working artist but also it is
not so expensive as to be Out Of Reach
for everybody also we are selling the
things that we made and the money from
that is going to go into the project for
awesome fun what an absolute Delight
thank you Sarah and thank you Kathy for
the camera work John I'll see you on
Tuesday there's an angle fish on the
wall an angle fish over there